Timmy who is your character Trent what
is he like Trent is sort of kind of from
left field he doesn't really get along
in group situations and he's kind of
always says the wrong thing though he
thinks he's think saying the right thing
like just he wants to be best friends
with their own but he has no ability to
do that to do so just kind of a goober
all around is it social anxiety what
what is it that makes him yeah um it's
well that's not so much anxiety is just
not knowing he can't do it like miles
his brother who is he's just think she's
like the pinnacle of cool he's got all
these follower he's got all these
friends he just can't match that sort of
it sort of cool that he thinks he's
always trying to but never quite can do
it and he just doesn't get it he can't
he hasn't really found who he is
basically ok interesting and this is
character on social media is he one of
the probably not he's not one of the
narcissists no my brother um miles are
your Trent sorry no no I'm just I just
film everything for my brother so he's
um so I'm just like kind of a lackey but
I'm totally happy being that yeah it's
kind of good to fit there and just help
him out right but he doesn't have his
own like online persona think so no hmm
no what's your take on all of this you
know the need to self-promote which is
important if you're an actor or whatever
business you have that you want to
promote but then there's another side
you can take it too yeah you can kind of
take it negatively right um I like I am
not used to that I've been acting
forever but like I've never really self
promoted at all i just got on twitter
but i did like just now like Oh week ago
and it's cool and I feel like it's
really important too because I mean
people connect and then you can work
with people through Twitter liking I
think that right like Jonathan he'd
that's how he got it connection with
James oh they tweeted each other I
between actually never asked them
okay they did a direct message each
other and then that's how we got it and
that's awesome it's like that sounds
awesome to me after thousands of
auditions you know just easy and it
comes with after you've done a lot of
stuff of course but it did for people to
be able to find each other easier that's
such a relief why so since you've only
been on Twitter a week is there anything
that you've been seeing either in your
weeks I mean I like I run reading
Twitter Twitter tweeter I'm new I know
what it is have you seen stuff that
appeals to you and then ways people do
things on social media that's a bit of a
turn-off so you can say oh I don't think
I want to be like that or I like how
this person was is I mean I want to
emulate that there's the O like it seems
like everywhere I go you see people in
their car doing the selfie I don't get
that really um it's it's a lot it's it's
super a leg it's not it's hard to say
it's egotistical because so many people
do it and I don't think that many people
are like like have giant egos I just
think it would they think that's what
you need to do and I don't think
everybody needs to do it I think some
people need to do it some people do it
well other people I mean just the girls
with the doing too much with the most of
the shots here third of shots here like
oh so so you either you're really bad at
aiming your camera or you know exactly
where you're aiming your camera so it's
kind of that mmm it's more about the
image than people and that's sort of we
get I mean what was 140 characters I'm
Twitter and that's not a lot to have a
reasonable debate for sure what seems
like with social media we always want to
project almost what we're not in some
ways or you know just kind of make
people think that our lives are a
hundred and ten percent better than they
really are by doing that and and what's
your take on that it was no one wants to
show the real stuff I mean
no one was to show the real stuff but we
don't do that anyway like we all get
dressed should we go out we don't cut
we're not showing the real stuff
anyway some do but don't do some do some
don't and that's I admire that but you
know you can kind of calculate and
that's good and bad you can be more
precise with what you're trying to say
and a lot of people that's people who
meet online and date and things that's
kind of great for them or awful for them
because they're seeing other liars or be
able to tell the truth and if you tell
the truth about yourself online i think
that's that's fair even if it's not the
whole truth but there are people just
absolutely fabricate where their whole
life is you know i'm always at the beach
this person is apparently never anywhere
else you know they're always having fun
with your friends and that's funny
you